foreign
and Mr Tyson
John
Fayetteville Police Department
you're not in your house
John
John
need you to wake up and talk to me
before I drag out drag you out here butt
naked
John
Fayetteville Police Department
you have two options either one is you
set up
and put your clothes on or two you go to
jail just like you are right now
all right
put your hands behind your back
oh
man's behind your back yo yo yo yo yo yo
yo
this isn't your house
hands behind your back you're under
arrest you're under arrest relax
put your hands behind your back very
relax
relax ow chill
what do you mean the Cuffs okay
go around my other side
oh relax John stop you're under arrest
thanks
yeah stop
you're under arrest for going to jail
okay now kick your feet out towards me
thank you
come on
John let's go John I was going to sleep
no you're not you're going into your
house so you're in the wrong house
the girl who lives here doesn't know you
came home to find you asleep in her bed
you
go with us officer let's go grab his
belongings go with him yes sir
foreign
foreign
make sure we got all this property
sit back
foreign
foreign
yeah should be
yeah it looks like he's trying to think
he's gonna pull his way out
foreign
foreign
oh yeah borrow mine since I borrowed
yours I've got an extra set okay yep
so does that mean that you currently
have one set of handcuffs on you you're
gonna have another one in my bag
okay so all right well we're gonna take
him to a safe but not nearly as
comfortable place to sleep okay all
right I don't know if he's
he's sitting there pulling pretty hard
on he's gonna fucking hurt himself but
he's being a jackass so
foreign